I love that you have a friendship with
the guys from the Fab five it's right
when did this happen
well it really happened when I saw the
show and I fell in love with great yeah
that's what happened but yeah I was just
a big fan of the show and then it
happened one Easter they came over 100
Johnny Jonathan came over and we had a
little bit of Easter together and then
it turned into kind of like a regular
clutch hangout yeah so then they came
over and then Anthony was finally able
to cover and then tan was finally able
to come over and the other two I haven't
met yet but looking forward to that okay
so if you had to get help with one of
the five areas which one do you need
help with most food culture interior
design fashion or grooming I don't know
I mean I did have me and Johnny Jonathan
went back to my bathroom one point when
he was getting his hair ready so I got
to watch him do that big gorgeous mane
of his and he gave me some tips he gave
me this like surf kommer stuff from
where we've put in my hair and and
already told me to get it and I did and
yeah so we've sort of we've already
tipped each other a little bit yeah I
kind of dick you Justin there I love
that you like embrace that old thing
yeah I would like to have him cook at
one point for me but he never does
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]